so you ever wonder why some people have
seasonal growth versus constant growth
what does this mean some people are like
oh my god i'm so motivated and excited
i'm going to go take over the world and
boom their business goes up goes up goes
up i just made 193 000 in a month and
we're killing our top line revenue
and then boom
62 000
seasonal versus constant what's the
difference let me explain it to you so
by the way if by the time i'm done doing
this video and this thing brings you
value and it makes sense you about to
have a breakthrough give it a thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel today's
sponsor is aura what aura does is
protect you against identity theft which
today it is the fastest growing crime in
all of america just last year 1.5
million americans experienced identity
theft for you know how much money ready
not 1 billion not 5 billion not 10
billion 52 billion dollars just last
year every 14 seconds somebody's
identity is stolen which means during
this video four to five people's
identity will be stolen and the reason
why this is important to me is i've been
in the financial industry for a long
time insurance finance we spend a lot of
money every year to protect against
cyber security attacks just a fun fact
one of our employees aaron went on their
website and he tested to see how many
times his identity had been stolen his
password over 40 times on the dark web
you may want to find out how many times
your identity has been stolen so if you
want to protect yourself from the
fastest growing crime in america visit
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14 day trial one more time
aura
aura.com forward slash valuetainment to
start your 14 day free trial with aura
try aura free for two weeks to find out
if any of your personal information or
your family's personal information has
been compromised let me get right into
it two things
um it's about 13 years ago
i'm sitting down with one of our best
guys whose business does 40 million
dollars your insurance
i'm sitting down with them
you know why is my business going
through with us
finally i'm like can i just explain to
you why your business keeps doing what
it's been doing
the last six years for you he says yes i
said here's why i said you don't make
permanent changes
you always make temporary changes what
do you mean let me explain
temporary changes you read a book you
watch a video
you watch a movie you get on a very
fiery zoom you know event somebody
challenges you motivates you makes you
believe you can do something you get
inspired so you make changes you stop
drinking soda you stop eating bread you
stop fooling around you stop getting
drunk every night you say i'm not gonna
smoke weed right now cause i'm gonna
stay focused and then your business
starts growing life starts growing
lifestyles and then boom you reach new
milestones and you go back to drinking
soda alcohol weed everything that you
were doing because you don't know how to
make permanent changes
you keep making temporary changes you
ever heard people when i was like i
watched rocky i'm fired up i'm gonna go
work out at the gym for six hours that's
not the right way to do it
i would much rather have you watch rocky
and watch a video that fires you up and
say the next two weeks no matter what
i'm at the gym 30 minutes every single
day for four days a week okay the next
two weeks that's what i'm going to be
doing
and even that
i would much rather you do 20 minutes of
workout three times a week for the rest
of your life let me say that one more
time not six hours in one day
not an hour
four times a week for the next 12 months
and that's it i'd much rather you do 20
minute workout
three times a week for the rest of your
life because that's a permanent change
this is a lifestyle this is guaranteed
this is temporary this you watch the
video you got excited this you watch a
motivational video oh my god i'm gonna
go take over the world and then you come
back down this is temporary this is
permanent
it's mathematically impossible for you
to think that life is dramatically going
to change by you making temporary
changes it's not it's the permanent
changes now when it comes down to
permanent changes the problem why so few
of us make permanent changes is because
we put the pressure of trying to change
seven different areas and you ain't
gonna do it
permanent changes don't work if you do
seven different things at a time
permanent changes work if you do one
thing at a time so i years ago in 2013
2012 i had an emergency meeting in uh
hotel in glendale california and i
brought everybody in i introduced a new
concept it's called dma's daily
monitoring activity what's daily
monitoring activity here's what i want
you to do what's your biggest stay in
phone calls one guy said i made 300
calls in a day awesome what's your
biggest thing running a sales
appointment i ran eight appointments in
a day great what's your biggest thing
going out there and prospecting i got
128 new numbers and they had a
networking event that was held at a
convention center and here's a business
card it's great
but here's what the dma is what's the
dma no matter what you do i don't care
if you're not in the right mood i don't
get the lakers lost i don't give things
are not going your way
no matter what i want you to make 50
calls a day
i want you to run no matter what four
appointments a day i want you to no
matter what prospect five people a day
oh i can do that i know you can do that
it's not i don't think you can do that
but i want you to do that 200 days
this year out of 365.
oh well that's that's that's i said
exactly but what i'm telling you is the
closest thing to guaranteed success
because it's permanent change not
temporary change so for you
if you're sick and tired of the cyclical
cycle you have in a business
start by making one
massive permanent change today in your
business and your life and you'll be
blown away by what's going to happen now
if you're a little bit more
ambitious and you want to do more do
three but don't do anything more than
three and stick to it and see what
happened to your life so
if that gave you a completely different
mindset and different hack to start
thinking about permanent changes over
temporary ones give us a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and i got
another video i want you to watch a
video i did a few years ago titled
seven habits of highly effective
entrepreneurs if you've never watched it
click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
you